hello and welcome to the Opera eme Leon
you charge chinese i am ok the college
system ok it's a solid opening not bad
at all ok quick 95 thought maybe like f
force ed ed night before is good I
staking ok ok let's capture towards the
center Oh is there some kind of tactic
here we should change takes checks that
might be a perpetual or repetition is
right ok maybe it's do this also to
avoid that
oh that's an interesting move but I can
take nd5 yes yeah this is good actually
check it's very very decent play for the
pawn if not more than that okay yes mmm
22 might be might be an annoyance IAM
hmm
should you for 22 I mean and I cannot go
back hmm should you fall looks good but
Queen d2 is spare is an annoying reply
okay problem maybe this one
huh interesting move
check definitely good good defense King
g2 and he has consolidated damn damn
damn damn hmm that didn't go too well I
really thought I have fantastic
compensation there huh remarkable either
I was completely wrong about that or I
didn't play it right hard to say I don't
know prenat Queen h3 is a funky moves
sometimes they take screen f9f to and
takes on d3 yet I don't don't really
know okay let's see if I can annoy him
here a little bit yeah if i take now I
mean this is Queen takes Knight of two
takes on d3 it's very funny very funny
line but you know this is also not so
easy cannot move the night now
he wants to wit
all right maybe still play 90 to me as
possible
you
f3 kanji 3 night a 320 X h3 so does it
look super easy okay he finds good moves
Knight f3 is probably coming so going
back
if i take g3 now night h 492 I can take
you six I want to go back and now is
Lucas trapped home still some life in
this position
down to a minute doe that's not good
no this is okay now really ok texas-pan
know where three ah got them okay I
still trapped okay it's still not
trapped I'm throw the f6 actually almost
is 96
so going 90 30 it takes will give 60
it's surprising check check check check
into jess circles check check don't see
the check no I'm just blundering
everypony what it is you're the game
check you really ain't did a lot to
check give me the point check check
check check check check no okay add just
one second it so i probably couldn't
have couldn't have done it anyway it was
probably very mystique and ridden this
game
okay so yeah here I didn't want to take
here because this is a draw yeah at
least I White has a drawer which was
kind of off-putting with g4 is also good
probably okay so we should be five and
really what was happening here why
didn't have a good position check this
yeah this was probably wrong there and I
didn't get it what was the deal a night
H file is good no I didn't see that one
I didn't have it on the radar that I
could trade Queen said of course look at
this position this is a terrible
position for white I guess and this for
this 96 that's fantastic for work
fantastic pollution and this was the
thing and here I mean China yet
absolutely untangled and then he sort of
all played himself a little bit from
this winning position hehe thank you put
his rook into into that that yeah I know
I should probably win but oh my what a
game it has been a very long session so
bear with me okay somewhat weird game
but i still hope it provided some
entertainment thanks for watching